comment vous voyez ce qui s'est passé au
cours des dernières heures et derniers
jours en fait c'est ça ne tend pas être
parfaite avec la situation actuelle où
depuis l'année depuis l'année dernière
aux etats-unis les grands courtiers on
penser à 0 de dollars de commissions
dont robin hood mais aussi les grandes
plateformes comme les traits de schwab
et compagnie l'autre chose qui s'est
passé c'est que il rien à faire donc
beaucoup de gens qui sont nouveaux dans
marchés boursiers puis le même phénomène
au canada donc les gens ouvrent des
comptes de courtage peuvent investir des
petites sommes et ont rien à faire donc
s'amuse donc il y ajoutant un nouveau à
nouvelle vague en fait d'investisseurs
qui sont peut-être plus des spéculateurs
que les investisseurs donc si une partie
de ce qui explique la folie des derniers
jours parce qu'on al'impression
effectivement qui est des gens qui tout
à coup se sont retrouvés à négocier sans
trop savoir ce qu'il faisait
des gens qui veulent faire de l'argent
peut-être déjà aussi qui veulent envoyer
des messages très clairs on attaque la
spéculation des fonds spéculatifs par de
la spéculation
oui effectivement donc le début de cette
histoire avec gamestop ce qui est
effectivement une entreprise qui est en
déclin et il ya des fonds spéculatifs
qui vendent à découvert le titre parce
qu'il prévoyait que le titre allait
baisser et la beauté c'est qu'un titre
monte et qu'on a une position découvrir
en titre on peut perdre beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup d'argent et ont réussi
à mettre à genou
un hedge fund quand même assez important
le danger c'est que je pense qu'il ya
des gens qui savaient que d'investir
dans une entreprise qui était en très
bonne santé financière équipe et ils
savent et qui paye un prix trop cher
pour le titre
et c'était le party de l'amusement mais
je pense que beaucoup de gens non
sophistiquée qui voit quelque chose
augmentée qui dit ah si j'avais investi
hier j'aurais doubler mon argent est
investi juste parce que ça montre sans
se poser de questions et je pense que
c'est probablement pour cette raison que
le québec ou courtiers qui ont qui ont
interdit le trading sur sur city club
pour éviter le quai
qui a beaucoup de gens aient des pertes
et savent pas pourquoi mais en même
temps est-ce que c'est la chose à faire
il ya des investisseurs qui doivent
sentir qu'ils font pas tout à fait
partie de la même catégorie que d'autres
types d'investisseurs que de voir la
plateforme robin wood particulièrement
interdire ou restreindre certaines
transactions
moi je pense que c'est exagéré et puis
l'establishment financier toujours
frustré quand il voit là de nouvelles
personnes de nouveaux acteurs rentrer
dans leur chasse gardée puissions viande
dans l'histoire c'est que ce soit
l'époque où il fallait avoir son siège
sur le parquet de la bourse existe plus
donc les gens se disent à beloeil plus
de gens ont accès au marché quand les
courtiers à escompte au téléphone son
arrivée a eu des mêmes phénomènes donc
il rien de nouveau sous le soleil je
dirais la seule chose qui ait de nouveau
parce qu'ils ont eu plein de bulles
spéculatives et de de défense de
l'industrie qui dit ben ça va trop loin
ce qui est l'espérance et la partie
ironique ou ont tout le monde
dès le début les gens savaient que
c'était pas un bon investissement et le
font pareil dont il est un peu un côté
des libérer de la masse parce que je
pense qu'il ya toujours vue d'aider des
gros investisseurs voulaient faire
bouger le titre c'est sur la partie mais
serait senti l'odeur de l'argent parce
qu'ils pourraient perdre de l'argent
oui c'est ce quand on investit dans une
bulle puis on sait qu'on paie trop cher
pour l'actif cesseront de six ans va
finir par tomber puis ils ont fait le
pari qu'on va vous êtes sûrs et n'obéit
avant que ça c'est font donc selon moi
les gens qui ont commencé ce mouvement
le survêt dit ont mis des montants
qu'ils étaient prêts à perdre l'enjeu
c'est qu'ensuite en voyant monter ça je
pense que plein d'autres investisseurs
qui ont se sont pas posé de questions
qui ont juste mis de l'argent un sport
de de faire du profit rapide c'est
dangereux pour vous ce qui se passe
selon vous c'est inquiétant mais je
dirais que rien de nouveau sous le
soleil et je pense pas que ça va être
généralisé dans la mesure où c'est assez
exceptionnel d'investir dans quelque
chose qui n'a pas de valeur
donc je pense pas que ça va changer le
marché boursier tel qu'on le connaît
peut-être que ça va rendre l'île
justement l'investissement de titres à
découvrir donc
c'est ce type d'investissement le plus
risqué parce que je pense que les gens
qui ont fait ces positions l'avait pas
vu venir une espèce de mouvement
populaire qui viennent des médias
sociaux pour l'heure pour en fait fort
en sorte qu'ils aient besoin couvrir la
position puis perdre des milliards de da
donc ça va ralentir les ardeurs c'est
peut-être là la barre pour initier une
position à découvert votre plus grande
parce qu'il ya un risque de plus alors
les fonds spéculatifs vont utiliser la
vente à découvert ils vont parier sur la
baisse du titre vont emprunter des
titres d'autres courtiers qu'ils vont
vendre dans le marché par exemple à 10
dollars en espérant que ça va baisser à
5 pour le racheter à 5 à ce moment là et
faire un gain mais là c'est pas ça
baisse passant que ça monte à 150
alors ils sont obligés de racheter et de
couvrir leurs pertes de réduire leurs
pertes au maximum en quelques sortes
f pas est-ce que vous pensez que ça
remet en question cet outil financier
cela s'appelle la vente à découvert
la vente à découvert et existe depuis
que le système capitaliste existe et il
ya des 10es plusieurs utilisations qui
sont très utiles
on parle de couvrir un risque donc on
pourrait utiliser les postures découvert
parce que on pense qu'ils ont un risque
systémique en même temps qu'une
industrie descendre ou s'effondre donc
on prépare pensée l'industrie automobile
on pourrait initier des positions
découvrir dans les joueurs les plus
faibles de l'industrie automobile et
acheter des dépositions investir dans
des entreprises sont le plus en santé il
là on viendrait faire prendre position
sur les meilleurs opérateurs en
automobile mais si l'industrie
automobile en entier based bas on est
pas pénaliser donc ces domaines je
comprends mais pour l'opération m mais
ce n'est pas quelque chose de cynique la
part de certains fonds de parier sur la
dégringolade la chute l'effondrement les
problèmes d'une entreprise pour en tirer
des gains c'est extrêmement frustrant
pour les pdg une entreprise qui voient
leurs titres faire l'objet de beaucoup
de positions à découvert
ça crée du stress a fait baisser le
titre et elle déteste les gens qui font
des dépressions des courants
par contre les gens qui les fonds
spéculatifs qu'ils font on l'argument
que eux sont là pour rétablir le juste
prix donc quand ils voient une
entreprise dont le prix est trop élevé
par rapport à sa valeur réelle d'un
prenne une position et cette position le
va faire baisser le titre le ramener à
sa juste valeur
donc c'est ce lit l'idée derrière
l'utilité de de tout ça en principe ça
fonctionne ensuite il ya des abus des
deux côtés le c'est un peu l'inversé
dans le cas de gamestop
c'est pas que le titre est trop bas par
rapport à sa valeur actuelle ce qui est
trop élevé le problème c'est pas
forcément le short selling mais c'est la
spéculation pour vous avez raison mais
c'est une attaque contre le short
selling et en même temps ce qui vient de
se passer sur gamestop et sur d'autres
entreprises
ok oui si je pense que je pense que ça a
marché parce que ça rend ce type de
position le plus risqué
je pense qu'à l'avenir les fonds
spéculatifs vont peut-être un peu moins
julien brault merci beaucoup merci